hallo leute hier ist wieder eure mal
wanne und willkommen zu einem neuen
video in dem ich mal endlich wieder die
koffer und zwar bin ich auf die idee
gekommen als ich denn am abels acryl
paint video gesehen habt ihr sie nicht
kennt main kanal ist einfach eine kopie
sie macht die verrücktesten videos
eigentlich gemacht alltägliche sachen wo
sie ein bild malt oder auch verrückte
sachen wie aus seife ein bisschen hund
bauen
sie ist einfach die tollste lustigste
frau auf youtube meiner meinung nach und
ich dachte mir bei dem acryl payne video
wie geil wäre das wenn man es packen
würde er ist in träumerische wenn wir
warten einen keks sehen wir dann als
leinwand benutzen und auch dieser keks
leinwand malen wir mit zuckerguss oder
weil eissing dies die profis sagen ein
bild hammer idee und vielleicht kann man
das sogar aufhängt wir müssen den
sim-lock machen dass man dazu einen bann
ziehen kann
safe safe kann man das aufhängen und wir
schauen jetzt einfach mal gemeinsam
wohin diese reise führt ob ich ein
abstraktes bild male oder vielleicht
doch die mona lisa war das ja bei
kennedy so gut geklappt hat alle zutaten
für einen keks leinwand sind einfach
keks zutaten und da muss ich mein nach
dem rezept schauen was ich dachte ich
kann das rezept aussehen seiten nehmen
die ich von meinem kochbuch schon
bekommen habe weil darin ein klicks
rezept ist ihr werde es niemals erfahren
sie warum da ein keks selbst drin ist
außer ihr cup ist das kochbuch
der erste link in der beschreibung da
könnt ihr euch das holt auch mal schade
ich dachte ich auch das rezept schon
hier aber ich hab nur die bilder von den
dozenten
schlimmer noch irgendein rezept für
unsere keks leinwand brauchen wir jetzt
mal butter kann manchmal auch mit dieser
akrobatik das ist hier auch langsamer
series business gebrauchen mail ein
kilogramm co2
vanille extrakt guter sogar und das
war's man kriegt ja hier keine
wissenschaft leute ich bin aufgedreht
bisschen nämlich was ich stecke mitten
im umzug ist also wirklich mittendrin in
fünf tagen sich um und ich muss alles
einpacken und ich will aber unbedingt
noch videos weitermachen main kanal sohn
stirbt jährlich erstmal müssen wir jetzt
in 600 gramm mehl und damals jetzt eine
ordentliche prise salz dazu kommen ein
bisschen seit ich alles mehr oder
weniger vermögen macht neben den finger
als er sei zu faul wie ich aber wir
müssen einfach die butter zusammen mit
puderzucker so schaumig schlagen und die
vanille zucker
irgendwann haben auch die eier dazu
[Musik]
leute creekside tun jeder mal gemacht
deswegen brauche ich das jetzt nicht
unbedingt zeigen wir sehen uns im
nächsten schritt wird sich gut lasst uns
eine leinwand backofen vorheizen gleich
einen einfachen zu ungefähr so groß wie
das backblech ist es doch schlachtens
mal aus wollen
ich hab kost bekommen von der firma
böckmann dankeschön sie haben ja auch
ein lama ausstecher geschickt was das
anders meistens auf der welt und ich
muss unbedingt noch lahmer klick zu
machen aber gesehen richtig mit nämlich
nicht kenntlich heißmann ist und ich
hätte gerne lange fahrenheit müssen
statt
ich glaub ich hab das mal viel teig
gemacht hier machen wir einfach zwei
leinwände und damit der sollte es nicht
werden dass wir uns allein wand da ist
schneiden wir uns das mal hier aus
[Musik]
ja das ist gut ich hoffe ihr könnt ein
bisschen sehen meinen pulli der
fördermittel verkauft jetzt größe
funktioniert schon mal so und damit wir
unsere bilder aufhängen können muss sich
jetzt aus ihrem loch entstand unter den
nada ist jetzt auch nicht mit ich ne
scheiße sollte doch klappen normale
klick zu kommen zehn minuten in den ofen
wie lange wird das braucht 15 ungefähr
ich war jetzt bisher offen aufgewärmt
ist dann kommt dass für ungefähr 10
minuten in den großen und wir sehen uns
dann wieder wenn das abgekühlt ist bis
gleich ich glaube dass stabil unsere
leinwand und wir haben sogar kleine
lamas und haben wir noch eine kleine
leinwand was ist jetzt eine eiweiß
glasur also dass zucker und eiweißpulver
drin und das mit wasser an
ich glaube erst mal drauf macht darin
wir schon wieder beim thema
hier machen wir mal die hälfte rein und
dann so ein bisschen wasser jetzt haben
wir unseren mit
jetzt nächsten wochen noch mehr wasser
start war super sein
direkt glaube ich das lassen wir jetzt
einfach auf ja
dann machen wir mit dem spachtel
ich versuche das jetzt so perfekt wie
möglich zu verteilen
mit deren schöne grundlage haben
[Musik]
hallo das ist erstmal ein bisschen
trockenen form nach für unsere lamas für
eine zweite leinwand
jetzt machen wir noch mehr holen icing
[Musik]
so gelangen sie zu trocken ich habe
keine ahnung aber wir sehen uns gleich
wieder
also jetzt von mir drauf malen und dafür
brauchen wir einen kameramann hyperworks
acrylfarbe in dem fall erfüllt ich habe
versucht die konsistenz davon zu machen
weil denn an ihrem video
dann legt sie farben so auch das bild
drauf und dann verschmiert sie es so und
das sieht so cool aus dass ich es auch
machen möchte wir versuchen es erst mal
auf dem kleinen dann müssen wir noch
eins werden wir lassen das jetzt im
änderung so bei mir bisher
dann müssten die speise auch einfärben
war ok go kart kortholt smart tv wo sie
an
sonst machen wir ein paar tropfen davon
unsere schlüsse pedrosa und das drückt
sie doch mal auswirkungen haben da
kannst du mir doch nicht erzählen machen
lila rosa und und freundlich scheiße
hier
dies ist magic magie und jetzt gemein
endlich denn am dienstag ein icon star
ja du machen fragte kunst
gute seht ihr aus wie ergriffen sind aus
wie also auch die waren dass er die
komplette verrückte ideen
ich wollte dass man sich überladen und
[Musik]
marquis bestimmt
ich ziehe es jetzt einfach wie sie so
hin und herfahren mit dem hellen an dass
sie cool aus dass das ist richtig
kunstmühle jackson pollock so brauch
klatschen die grenzen sind endlich
unendlich brustbild auf den keks
die 3d mäßig sein man kennt das ist auch
so nehmen und ineinander so verzwickt
wir lassen das so das volk hatte doch so
richtig denkt sieht riegler anna peters
wir sehen diesen kleinen penis das
lassen wir so khom einem kleinen bild
habe ich mich jetzt an diese abstrakte
acrylat gehalten machen wir bei dem
größeren hatte ich schon lust ein
bisschen mehr auf die kacke zu hauen wir
benutzen jetzt die pinsel und dann ja
[Musik]
jetzt mein gesunder richtig schöne rose
aber so barbara rose das öl farben das
40 grad anderem mit ölfarben werden
blumen sind teil umzug macht spaß das
leben in den großen play button machen
können sie nicht ganz so klaus das
wollte das war ein dienstags bild
jeweils künstlerin du sieht auf den
ersten blick natürlich immer toll aus
die idol sitzt dann mal dienstag bilder
ja das denkt man
[Musik]
es steckt so viel
ok wow der giftigste stehen hier gesehen
habe sie so richtig kitschig aus dem
haus geschickt gemacht sagen wir machen
jetzt um es richtig kitschig zu machen
über noch herzchen hin das muss so
richtig kleines bild lage sind den
annahmen
[Musik]
weißt du was wir jetzt machen mit des
feuers ist das sieht schön aus und jetzt
machen wir wieder am nächsten zu tun
dass ich absolut unzufrieden mit dem
bitten 19
das heißt auch über video
[Musik]
störrische kunz
der mit ihr organ geschaut und
schöpferische zerstörung oder so
zerstörerische shops man hier lebt ok
superliga durchschnittlich nicht
es ist doch immer so scheint es könnten
da wird einfach im bild seine
bilderrahmen
ach so und jetzt werdet ihr ein bild
davon sehen wie es an meiner wand hängt
wenn es getrocknet ist wow das war cool
aus oder hab ich mal für euch das video
gefallen wenn ja dann gibt dem video
einen daumen nach oben folgt mir auch
instagram um eine ipad bilder nicht zu
verpassen
abonniert diesen kanal und können videos
nicht verpassen ich habe auch eine
mehrkanal wird ab diesem jahr videos
kommen werden auch abonnieren und kauft
mein kochbuch erst dein link in der
beschreibung
da macht es nach das macht voll spaß
oder ein paar freunde und macht
kriegsbilder